KASIA DERC-FENSKE: Hi.
My name's Kasia, from the Google
Enterprise Geo Support
Team in Europe.
We've prepared a series of
videos for you to help you get
started with Maps API
for Business.
This video will cover the
process of creating digital
signatures.
Let's assume we were to build
a car sharing solution.
They'll use self-driving cars
that can pick you up at any
given location.
The cars will send us a lat/long
par, and we'll need
to convert it to a human
readable address.
We'll be using the
reverse geocoding
web service for that.
Let's open up the
documentation.
I'll use my bookmarks to
navigate to the Google Maps
API web services, and then to
the Geocoding API section.
Then I'll choose reverse
geocoding, and
copy the sample URL.
Now I'll set the sensor
parameter to false, because my
browser isn't geo enabled.
And we get the result.
It geocoded the lat/long par to
Bedford Avenue in Brooklyn.
But if you make such a request,
we won't know that
you're a Maps API for
Business customers.
In order for our servers to
identify this request as Maps
API for Business, you need to
add your client ID parameter.
This will allow you to take
advantage of the Maps API for
Business benefits, such as
higher quotas, and more weigh
points for the direction's
API.
Adding your client ID also
entitles you to Maps API for
Business Technical Support.
But what happens if I add
a client parameter?
I got an error message saying,
"Unable to Authenticate the
Supply URL.
Please check your client and
Signature Parameters." That
suggests that we need
to sign our URLS.
I'll go ahead and look at the
enterprise documentation to
see if we find any
pointers there.
I'll navigate to the web
services section.
As you see, we have a section
on digital signatures, and
generating valid signatures.
So to give you a brief overview
of this section, it
summarizes that when you send
a web service request, you
need to sign it with your
private key that was sent to
you're welcome letter.
Now let me show you what
a sample welcome
letter looks like.
So the title is, Welcome to
Google Maps API for Business.
And then you'll find that you
have a client ID in the letter
and a crypto key.
We'll use that crypto key
to sign our requests.
OK.
Let's go back to the docs.
So having the client ID and
having to crypto key, the next
thing you'll need to do is to
sign your request using
HMAC-SHA1 function.
But what is HMAC-SHA?
SHA1 is a hash function that
can create a check sum of a
file, or of a request.
It's just like [? MD5-sum ?].
HMAC stands for hash based
message authentication code,
and is a way to create
a signature.
Which is called a message
authentication code that uses
both the cryptographic hash
function and a secret key.
So just like the crypto
key we have.
The good thing is, it
guarantees both data
integrity, and authenticity.
That means nobody can change
the message because
we'll detect it.
And what's more, we'll
know that the
message comes from you.
OK.
I'll use the Python Interactive
Shell to generate
the valid signature.
So let's have a look
at the steps.
First, we need to construct
our URLs, making sure the
client and sensor parameters
are there.
Then, we'll need to strip
off the domain
portion of their request.
And sign it using HMAC-SHA1
algorithm and aerocrypto key.
There's a bunch of other things
that we need to take
care off, like making sure that
all the characters are in
the request, or URL
in the codec.
Well, we'll get to this
as we start coding.
Let's start the Python Shell.
And import URL lib and
base 64 libraries.
Great.
Then we'll define the Google
API's URL, and the reverse
geocoding endpoint.
Now let's have a look at the
request we made before.
It had lat/long parameter, and
a sensor parameter, and a
client parameter.
OK.
I'll use the URL lib URL in
code function to make sure
that my parameters are
properly encoded.
OK.
I have the lat/long par.
I have the client parameter.
And I have the censor parameter
set to true.
Because we'll be sending
that request from
self driving cars.
Next, I'll need to retrieve
my private key.
Actually, you should never,
ever share your
private with anyone.
But since I can delete it
afterwords, it's not that big
of a problem.
But a private key is generally
like a password.
And it's better not to show
it to people who are not
supposed to see it.
OK.
Let's have a look
at the steps.
So we already have the Client
and censor params in place.
We'll construct the main portion
of the request soon.
We have our private key.
And the only thing we
need to do now is--
and code the resulting
string using
that HMAC-SHA1 algorithm.
OK.
First of all, let's
decode our key.
The key is binary and it's only
presented to you in this
way because it was
base 64 encoded.
So if I printed the key right
now, it does look binary.
OK.
Now let's import the hash leap
and HMAC libraries, and
construct the URL
we want to sign.
We have reverse geocoding end
point and then encoded parms.
Let's print it to make sure
this is the right thing.
Yeah, looks good.
As you see all the characters
need to be your own coded.
So that's why the comma sign was
encoded to present to "C."
Now first, we need to generate
a new instance of the HMAC
function with our crypto key,
with our decoded crypto key.
Now after I cold digest,
I'll get the signature.
But the signature will
be binary, just
like the decoded key.
So we need to URL save and
base 64 encode it.
OK.
So it looks like we have
the encoded signature.
Let's print it.
Looks good, there are no low
standard characters, it
doesn't look binary,
just about right.
Let's try to construct
the URL.
Lat/long parameters is there,
the client parameter is there,
sensor parameter is there,
signature is there.
OK.
Let's try it.
We'll use the URL
open function to
construct the handler.
And let's issue the
Read function.
Wonderful.
Maybe now we want to see it in a
browser to look at it better
for a minute.
I'll simply copy this, and
place it in the browser.
OK.
It works.
So this is how you generate
valid signatures.
It's important to remember that
every time the request
changes, you need to regenerate
the signature.
So for example, if I changed
the lat/long parameter, the
request could stop working.
And I would need to regenerate
the signature.
On our web page, we have a list
of signature examples,
and different code snippets
for different languages--
like C sharp, Java,
and Python.
All the resources used in this
video are included in the
comments below.
That includes codes snippets
and bookmark expert.
Thanks for listening.
And check out our YouTube
channel for new [? videos. ?]